ALLEGATIONS HAVE SURFACED.
CAPITOL HILL IS GETTING OUT OF
POLITICS.
PROSECUTOR SAYS HE'S RETURNING
CORRESPONDENT BACK IN MY
>> I CALL UPON ALL OF US TO SET
ASIDE OUR DIFFERENCES.
>> REPUBLICAN LEADERS HOPE
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S EFFORTS TO
TOP HOUSE DEMOCRATS ARE NOT
CHANGING THEIR TUNE.
>> ONE SPEECH DOESN'T ERASE A
CONFLICT RIDDEN CHAOTIC YEAR
THAT STRIVEN OUR COUNTRY EVEN
FURTHER APART.
>> LEADERS FACING RETIREMENTS.
TREY GOWDY IS 1 OF 9 HOUSE
COMMITTEE CHAIRS ANNOUNCING THEY
DONE.
REPUBLICAN LAWMAKERS INTEND TO
SET THEIR AGENDA FOR THE REST OF
2018.
>> WE'LL BE SPENDING TIME AROUND
INFRASTRUCTURE, WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AS WELL AS THE
DEMOCRATS SUPPORT IS ON
REBUILDING INFRASTRUCTURE.
>> WE'VE BEEN THROUGH SO MANY
BATTLES.
HOPEFULLY WE GET THE ABILITY TO
START PUTTING THE REAL MEAT ON
THE BONE.
>> THE PRESIDENT PRESENTS
HIMSELF AS A MAN OF BIG IDEAS
AND THEN HE PRESENTS A LAME,
PUNY INFRASTRUCTURE PROPOSAL.
>> FACING THE GOVERNMENT FUNDING
DEADLINE NEXT WEEK AND A DACA
DEADLINE IN MARCH, A SENATE
REPUBLICAN SAYS IT'S TIME FOR
DEMOCRATS TO GET SERIOUS.
>> WE HAVE TO DO SOMETHING ON
THE BORDER AND WANT TO MAKE SURE
SCHOOL OR CURRENTLY EMPLOYED
PRESSURE, CONGRESSIONAL BUDGET
OFFICE SAID LAWMAKERS WOULD
LIKELY NEED TO RAISE THE DEBT
CEILING IN EARLY MARCH.
THE PREVIOUS ESTIMATE WAS
CONGRESS HAD UNTIL LATE MARCH OR